Mary here with a gamespot news update it
looks like we finally have details on
when the Xbox timed exclusive rise of
the Tomb Raider will be coming to other
consoles specific release dates for pc
and ps4 weren't revealed but publisher
square enix did share release windows it
will be out on pc in early 2016 and ps4
sometime in holiday 2016 there was no
mention of a ps3 version see xbox one
and xbox 360 versions which microsoft is
publishing remain on track to release on
november 10th 2015 Square Enix notes the
game will be on the console exclusive
for one year after its initial launch
last year there was some confusion about
whether rise of the Tomb Raider would
ever make it to gnaw on Xbox platforms
it was announced at Gamescom as an Xbox
exclusive but Xbox boss Phil Spencer
later clarified that it was merely a
timed exclusive meaning it would come to
other platforms later at a specific time
rise of the Tomb Raider is the sequel to
2012 Tomb Raider reboot the sequel was
announced at e3 2014 and is described as
a survival action adventure will you
will join lara croft on her first tomb
raiding expedition as she seeks to
discover the secret of immortality so
after months of speculation and a little
confusion it looks like rise the tomb
raider does have a release window on
other platforms for the latest on rise
of the Tomb Raider stay tuned to
gamespot com